ich hab einen freunde wieder und wer
hatte lief alles klar
bislang wurde nicht von ihr geschrieben
wichtig dass auch leute liegt was in der
luft
irgendwas ist heute anders irgendwas um
uns spiele für die braucht gab eine
verschiebung in der macht irgendwas ist
passiert wenn ich richtig ihn nicht rein
höhere spüre ich dass irgendwas aus der
richtung des produkt palast kommt könnt
ihr die angestellt haben leute heute
viel spaß sagen heute spaß haben wir
hatten ein kleines video für einen
eigenen vorn gemacht alter endlich lange
lange her dass ich ein video über bibi
gemacht habe aber ich hab's geführt
heute liegt in der luft wurden ich habe
echt viele kollegen angeschrieben haben
gemeint du hast ja wir hatten neues
video ich mache jetzt anfangen ich
glaube du musst jetzt mal anschauen und
wir im recht deswegen film ab
hallo baby was haben wir denn hier
da hast du wieder zugeschlagen 123456
mit rollt wir haben uns lange nicht mehr
gesehen aber du bist immer noch dabei du
willst immer noch ein game ich merke das
respektiere ich wäre ja auch langweilig
denn wie die einfach nur eine mit würde
also nein wir sind wieder mit sechs mit
roth am start und das war nur die ersten
sekunden des videos okay leute wisst ihr
was wir spielen das gleiche spiel wie
damals auch schon bei ihm einen video
wie gemacht hat und zwar zu spielen
sportreporter place hat okay halt
einfach zu seinem ausflug platzierung
und wer sie zuerst bemerkt hat gewonnen
laubsdorf glock ich habe eine ganz
ehrlich was wir der produkt palast oder
die platzierung natürlich haben wir auch
in diesem song ein paar placement von
warner music germany also ich meine ich
wirklich gemein sein oder so aber wir
haben schon 54 und über die musiker dem
wall e on die musiker wir haben von
reggae musik gehört werden vom ksd musik
gehört ich meine es war jetzt keine
musikalischen ergüsse ich glaube man ist
nicht gemeint sondern einfach
realitätsnah wie man sagt das ist
wahrscheinlich nicht so schön
die menschen freuen können informationen
zu erzählen heute eher wisst ihr was
gerade recht die stimmung ist heiter bb
forisch ich bin euphorisch das wird ein
gutes video leute plate radar schlägt
wieder aus wir haben ein werbevideo das
zählt eigentlich auch als als sporting
hat es bemerkt wie heißt du bist ja gut
wann kommt eigentlich wie halt dein maul
ich wollte nur wissen meine neue song
von baby achtmal leuten egal wie du
siehst echt und autor wissen was läuft
man muss die reinen charlotte die gute
kriegt einfach hin wirklich mit allem
geld zu machen
wahrscheinlich irgendwelcher von ihr
gesagt you baby weißt du wie du noch
mehr geld verdienen kannst du ja wir
haben voll die coole idee so für dich so
so könnten von produzieren es hat auch
noch gar kein lied über gemacht und wenn
er es gemacht hat das bisher immer
richtig gut was kann damit verdienen
sämtliche zwölfjährigen mädchen in
deutschland und libyen gibt es auch
finanziell nicht so schlecht was soll
das denn du musst doch wirklich sehr
jungen zuschauer nicht so eine panik
machen was denkt ihr was die
zwölfjährige anna aus erkelenz denkt
wenn sie dieses video sieht und baby
sagt aber wenn ihr jetzt nicht
vorgestellt dann habt ihr verkackt dann
bekommt ihr die cd vielleicht nie dann
denke die töpfe ghana ich weiß ich muss
mal wirklich mit dem verlustängsten von
leuten werben wie also irgendwie doch in
anderen beigeschmack wie wir das macht
und irgendwie keine ahnung den also was
sagt irgendwas anderes baby ist so das
ist eher ein hauch von produktpalette
einfach selbst bemerkt wie gras bereit
und eindringlich sie gerade so den fang
vermute dass du nach vier minuten 30 uhr
kurze wache sekunde das ok wo ich lieber
tribes gerade richtig meinte weiter die
chronisch auch vorziehen so als running
gags weil ich eigentlich die
veröffentlichung aber das kann halt
nicht jeder youtuber macher so es gibt
halt leute die bei denen funktioniert
und es gibt leute bei dir passiert das
nicht und bei dir funktioniert nicht bei
dir ist einfach die trans alles klang
wurde nicht von ihr geschrieben
genauso haben haben wir einen partner
musik fahrer quasi gesucht um das
richtig große man es nicht auf einem
posten liegt sein aufnehmen das youtube
video hochladen
leider nicht so viel geld wird mir
gerade aufhält ich glaube baby ist der
einzige mensch der wirklich reizen
minutenlang dauergrinsen kann und die
komplette maus später zu bekommen müsste
man darauf achten dass wirklich nur die
hat er wieder alles neu hier ist wie so
eine leichte verspannungen die gasse tor
wo andere music mein erstes eigenes volk
kommt zum dauergrinsen wirklich gleich
zu leben also überlegt euch mal worst
case ihren geht über die straße und
erlebt irgendwie ein auto und teile
leute verletzt sind und ihr habt einfach
dieses dauergrinsen youtube-videos werde
drauf haben müsst um möglichst positiv
zu wirken möglichst zu verkaufen und
dann lauft ihr zu einem autounfall
vorbei so alles verkehrt was finden
jetzt daran so schön diese menschen
verletzt können sie bitte weiter werden
wisst ihr was leute ich bin bibi immer
so hin und hergerissen die sagt
teilweise einfach echt kein unsinn und
man kann auch niemandem vorwerfen dafür
mit youtube geld verdienen möchte aber
baby hat irgendwie sowas ansicht ist so
so eiskalt und so berechnend und das
gepaarten diesem kranken dauert und dass
das verursacht diese leichte
abwehrreaktionen karte hat nur zwei mal
ausgeschlagen einmal bei dem produkte
sind einmal dass es ein werbevideo ist
also das ganze video ist einfach nur
werbung für den einen song was wir
daraus viele leute ich bin eigentlich
für weniger helfen youtube deutschland
ich mache immer so videos wo ich ein
bisschen schießen aber ich hasse die
menschen ja nicht ich mache mich lustig
darüber das ist nicht großartig amüsiert
mich einfach hinter youtube deutschland
dazu und man amüsiert sich darüber also
meine meinung zusammengefasst lassen wir
ihr ding machen und das ein baby ihr
geld machen und arbeiten spaß damit
lachen drüber super in diesem sinne zwei
leicht- und zeigen zurzeit und bis zum
nächsten mal